hey guys welcome to the simply learn
live on the best books for learning data
science
before we get started let's wait for a
bit as people join in
thank you to everyone joining us from
youtube and facebook
once again i'd like to welcome everyone
to this live session on the best books
for learning data science
before we begin i'd like to remind you
all that we have a dedicated team here
to answer your questions
so if you have any ask away in the
comment section below
do you often watch netflix have you ever
wondered how netflix predicts the shows
of your liking
or have you ever wondered how amazon
suggests
items for you to purchase how do you
think they do it
in reality doing such tasks requires the
availability of
data and data science is all about using
data to solve
problems i am keerthana and in today's
video let us look at some of the best
books for data science
i've categorized these books into three
groups to make it simpler for you all
best books for beginners
best advanced books and best
non-technical books
initially let us look at some of the
best data science books for beginners
kindly note that the list of books is in
no particular
order initially we have
practical statistics for data scientists
by peter c bruce andrew bruce and peter
grech
this book is ideal for absolute
beginners and one of the must-have data
science books
which imparts an overview of various
concepts regarding data science
covering a vast range of data science
topics
this book is written in an easy to
understand language
statistics is very important in data
science
this book is not too detailed but gives
good enough information about statistics
in data science
and some in-depth topics like
distribution
randomization sample bias sampling
etc this book serves as a quick
and easy reference for beginners so
if you are starting from scratch this
book is for you
talking about the authors peter bruce is
the founder and president
of the institute for statistics
education
at statistics.com the leading provider
of online education in statistics
he is the developer of resampling stats
software
andrew bruce he is a serial entrepreneur
with more than 20 years of experience
in the software and energy industries
he is the founder and ceo of data gumbo
which is streamlining smart contracts
for oil
and gas through the leading edge use of
its blockchain technology network
gambonet peter gedak
is at the forefront of the use of data
science in drug discovery
he is a senior data scientist at
collaborative drug discovery
which offers the pharmaceutical industry
cloud-based
software to manage the huge amount of
data
involved in the drug discovery process
his research interests include
the application of statistical and
machine learning methods
to problems in drug discovery
up next we have introduction to machine
learning with python a guide for data
scientists
by andreas c mueller and sayra guido
data science and machine learning are
very closely related
and the knowledge of machine learning is
very important for a data science
professional
this book covers the basics of machine
learning and has all the examples with
python
you need not worry if you do not have
any prior knowledge of python language
this book will help you learn that as
well as this is a book for beginners to
understand the basics of
ml and python the tone is friendly and
easy to understand
once you are through with this book it
is recommended that you take an advanced
level book to learn more about python as
well as machine learning
talking about the authors andreas muller
received his phd
in machine learning from the university
of bonn
after working as a machine learning
researcher on computer vision
applications at amazon
for a year he joined the center for data
science
at new york university sarah guido is a
data scientist at
rionomy where she is helping to build
disruptive tech
in the commercial real estate industry
in new york
city three of our favorite things are
python
data and machine learning up next
is introduction to probability by joseph
k
blitzstein and jessica huang having
noted that probability holds immense
importance in the field of data science
this book introduces you to concepts of
probability
by taking real life problems as the
examples
if you're already familiar with the
basics of probability
this book will benefit you to further
your knowledge of the basic
concepts if you are completely new to
probability
then you will have to spend a little
extra time on this book
talking about the authors joseph
blitstein is the professor of the
practice and statistics at harvard
university
he has taught a wide range of
undergraduate and graduate probability
and statistical courses at harvard he
is also a chess expert and serves as
faculty advisor to the hardware chess
club
next we have r for data science by
garrett grohlmund and hadley wickham
this is a perfect book which introduces
you to r
for data science it will teach you about
many aspects of our programming language
focusing on data wrangling data
exploration
and data modeling with r this book also
provides you with different r
tools for solving various data problems
easily
and quickly this book is divided into
various sections
each section tackles different aspects
of data science
along with some exercises that will help
you to further understand the concepts
better
talking about the authors garrett
grolman has earned a bachelor's degree
in psychology from harvard university
he has also earned his phd in statistics
from rice university in 2012.
he works for our studio as both an
educator
and advocate of data science with r
hadley wickham is a statistician from
new zealand who is currently
chief scientist at our studio and an
adjunct professor of statistics at the
university
of auckland stanford university and
rice university his major fields are
statistics
data science and our programming
language
let us now look at some of the best
advanced level data science books
python data science handbook by jake
windplus a classic handbook for data
science in python
this book will introduce you to various
tools in python
like ipython numpy jupiter
pandas etc this book serves as a
comprehensive desk reference
that can be used by both beginners and
also experienced professionals
if you are someone who is well
acquainted with the basics of python and
data science
this is the best book to take your data
science skills and notch up
talking about the author jake vandeplas
was formerly both the director of open
software
and the director of research in physical
sciences
for e-science institute he comes from a
background of machine learning and data
intensive
astronomy and astrophysics
he received his bs in physics and
phd in astronomy up next we have
practical data science with r by john
mount
and nina zumel this book lives up to its
name
it explains the basic principles and
jumps
right into the real use cases that you
will face while collecting
curating and analyzing data
it shows you how to apply the r
programming language
and useful statistical techniques to
everyday business situations
it has established itself as the best
statistics book
for data science if you are looking
forward to seeing
yourself as a top data scientist you
should consider making this book as your
best friend
talking about the authors john mount is
the author of several
r packages his interests include
data science statistics r programming
and theoretical computer science he is
the co-founder
and principal consultant at win vector
llc
a san francisco data science consultancy
nina zumel is also a principal
consultant
at win vector llc a data science
consulting and training firm her
interests include
data science statistics statistical
learning
and data visualization of late
she has also become heavily involved
with data science related training
and teaching she has developed various
courses
and materials on machine learning and
data science
up next we have deep learning by eon
goodfellow
yeshua bengayo and aaron corville
definitely an amazing book for deep
learning algorithms
this book is not code heavy but explains
in depth how to approach
deep learning problems the book is
targeted towards university students
learning about deep learning machine
learning
and artificial intelligence the authors
have also mentioned
lots of insights to understand what
machine learning is
and how one can implement it for solving
modern-day problems
we have three authors for this book as i
mentioned
eon goodfellow who has made several
contributions in the field of deep
learning
is a researcher working in machine
learning currently employed at apple
inc as its director of machine learning
in the special projects group
he was previously employed as a research
scientist
at google brain yeshua bengio is a
canadian computer scientist
he is recognized as one of the world's
leading experts
in artificial intelligence and a pioneer
in deep learning
he is a professor at the department of
computer science
and operations research at the
university of montreal
aaron corville is a computer scientist
whose current research focuses on the
development
of deep learning models and methods
he has a phd in computer science from
the carnegie mellon university
up next we have data science and big
data analytics
by emc education services
this book is about harnessing the power
of data for new
insights it covers the breadth of
activities
tools and methods that data scientists
use
this book will help you become a
contributor on a data science team
it'll help you learn how to tell a
compelling story with data
to drive business actions additionally
it'll help you apply appropriate
analytic techniques
and tools to analyze big data
our last category is the best
non-technical books for data science
the data science handbook advice and
insights from
25 amazing data scientists
this book is a collection of interviews
with 25
prominent data scientists where they
share
their insights stories and advice
if you are planning to build a career in
data science and wondering
what roles this field covers what it
entails
whether it is right for you or not this
book is for you
the 25 data scientists hail from
different backgrounds
disciplines and industries some of them
were part of the trail blazing wave of
data scientists
who catapulted the field into national
attention
whereas some others are at the start of
their careers
the data scientists in the book touch
upon some common carrier questions
like what does it take to build an
effective data science team
what lies in the future of data science
and many more
at last we have naked statistics
by charles whelan this book starts with
the fundamental concepts of statistics
like normal distribution central limit
theorem
etc and goes on to complex real world
problems
this book explains the core notions of
the subject
by linking them with real life scenarios
the tone of the book is witty and
conversational
the book correlates data analysis and
machine learning
it aims at delivering mind-boggling
contents from the world of statistics
in a comedic style all in all
if you are new to data science this book
will make you laugh
while understanding statistical concepts
although this book requires some degree
of experience
with statistics it succeeds at
delivering the intended knowledge in a
manner that is highly unique
talking about its author born in 1966
charles whelan is an american professor
journalist
and speaker he is the founder and
co-chairman of united america
his other books include naked economy
naked money
and many more and there you go
that's our list of best books for
learning data
science with that we've reached the end
of the video
think we missed anything important let
us know in the live chat or in the
comment section below
if you're watching it later thank you
for watching the video and stay tuned
for more from simply
learn
you